hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
this right here is Apple's brand-new 16
inch MacBook Pro it's actually almost
fully Specht out we've got the 2.4
gigahertz 8 core i9 we've got 32 gigs of
ram and the highest end AMD 5500 M 8
gigabyte graphics compared to the top
spec 2015 MacBook Pro right here it's
got the top-end
2.8 gigahertz quad core i7 it's got 16
gigabytes of RAM and the best AMD
graphics that you can get along with the
once hair buy SSD that we also get on
the other 16 inch macbook pro as well so
in this video we're gonna compare the
differences between basically everything
between these two machines including
these speakers the microphones the
display quality bezels the keyboards the
track pads all of that stuff we're gonna
compare in this video because I know a
lot of you out there are holding on to
your old 2015 MacBook Pros because you
were reluctant to upgrade to the newer
design with the Thunderbolt 3 USB ports
first things first we're gonna start
comparing the design now you guys may
have noticed the glowing Apple logo on
the back of the MacBook Pro right here
that's what a lot of people are missing
honestly it's been so long that I don't
really miss the Apple logo anymore but
it is definitely nice to have now one of
the reasons why we have that and we
don't have it anymore
is because Apple tried to make it
thinner so let's close these down and
compare the thickness of both of these
so putting them side-by-side you can
actually tell that the new 16 inch
MacBook Pro even though it's thicker
than the 15 inch it's still thinner than
the old 2015 15 inch and another thing
we noticed with this new 16 inch is that
it was slightly bigger overall compared
to the 15 inch but what's interesting is
that when we stack these on top of each
other they're actually basically
identical so the new 16 inch is just
like the size that the old 2015 15 inch
used to be now another interesting
difference is that the hinge on the 2015
model is actually plastic but other than
that there isn't really that much of a
difference looking at these on the
exteriors now the 2015 model is actually
a little bit heavier I believe it's four
and a half pounds compared to 4.3 pounds
on the 16-inch so that's nice that it's
a little bit lighter now let's get into
the ports which is probably the biggest
reason why a lot of people stuck with
the 2015 instead of upgrading to the
newer design with a Thunderbolt 3 ports
so here we've got the two Thunderbolt 2
ports which aren't really that useful
anymore to be honest but of course you
can connect two displays you've got USB
a you've got the MagSafe charger which
is definitely really nice we don't have
that anymore you've got another usb on
this side you actually get an HDMI
display for connecting to external
monitors and of course you get the SD
card reader which is really nice for the
photo editors out there the only
downside of these SD card slots is that
they only support transfer speeds of up
to around 100 megabytes per second
compared to up to around 300 if you get
the right adapter for USB C on these
newer MacBook Pros and of course with a
16 inch MacBook Pro you get four
Thunderbolt three ports which you can do
a lot of things with there's a lot of
adapters out there now let's open them
up and compare the interior design so as
you guys can see right here the layout
is very very similar you've got the
speakers on the size out there you've
got the keyboard you got the trackpad
but there are some really big
differences here first of all the
trackpad on the new 16 inch is massive
it's like twice as big as the old one
now this one was the new force touch
trackpad it was the first year to get
the force touch trackpad so it
definitely feels really nice but you
just get so much more space with the
newer one we can see that the hinge on
the new one is definitely a little bit
more low-profile it doesn't stick out as
much right here and we have that MacBook
Pro logo right there and moving on to
the keyboard the new 16 inch does get
the touch bar right here compared to the
physical keys on the old model which
definitely are nice they're really quick
and easy to use I don't really like the
touch bar that much but I am happy that
we do get the physical Escape key with
the 16 inch and the separated touch ID
with the power button right here which
is also really nice and another
difference I'm noticing on the keyboard
is that the 16 inch has wider keys
they're bigger overall compared to these
smaller chiclet style keys right here
and I can also easily see some backlight
bleed around the keys themselves on the
2015 model whereas
the 16-inch macro and basically
everything since 2016 has the nicer
underglow that's built into the key now
let's compare the feel of the keys
themselves right going over here on the
2015 model and they definitely have a
lot of key travel which is really nice
but the keyboard does seem kind of loud
it's definitely louder than what I'm
used to with these newer MacBook Pros
and the key travel is nice but it does
feel a little bit mushy like I don't
know you just don't get a lot of
feedback from this and moving over to
this if you guys haven't seen our
15-inch for 16 inch macbook pro
comparison we did notice a lot more heat
travel like I'm a lot more keyboard feel
it feels so much better than the
butterfly keys so overall I definitely
prefer the newer keyboard on the 16 inch
macbook pro because they did add in some
extra key travel and it definitely feels
nicer with that extra springiness now we
also see a massive difference in these
displays first of all the bezels on the
2015 model are massive they're so huge
compared to the 16 inch model which
recently did get the bezels shrink down
a little bit compared to the 15-inch so
it looks a lot nicer more modern and
comparing these side-by-side the
difference is just huge in the bezels I
also notice a huge difference in the
color temp of these displays
now the 2015 model does not have true
tone technology which the 16 inch
obviously does and just looking at it
like this right here the 2015 looks so
blue I'm on Google's website which is
supposed to be nice and white but it
looks super blue compared to the 16 inch
which has like a nice paperwhite feel to
it and there's also a massive difference
in the maximum display brightness
comparing these side-by-side the new 16
inch MacBook Pro is just so much
brighter than the old 2015 model this is
going to help in bright environments
reducing the effect of reflections and
stuff like that it's gonna be a lot
nicer to have that brighter display now
before we move on I want to mention that
the 16 inch MacBook Pro does get better
color accuracy
it supports P 3 wide color gamut well
the 2015 model does not and now let's
get into something I'm really really
excited for comparing the speakers let's
see how far a police got informed
speaker quality now we know that the 16
inch recently got our hue
upgrade in the speakers these just
sounds so much better and more clarity
better in every single way especially
bass so let's compare these two
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I don't know if you guys
could tell the difference depending on
what kind of speakers you guys are using
but there is a massive difference with a
16 inch you get better volume you get
better clarity you get better highs mids
lows the separation of all those
frequencies as well works very very well
on the 16 inch macbook pro and i can
honestly say that anybody doing music
production could actually use these
speakers for producing music and stuff
like that because they're very very
accurate all the frequencies just sound
very good on the 60 inch macbook pro the
new 16 inch pro also gets upgraded
studio-quality microphone so let's go
ahead and compare a FaceTime video clip
on each model this is a FaceTime video
and audio quality test on the 2015 15
inch macbook pro and this is a video and
audio quality tests on the new 16 inch
macbook pro now let's get into comparing
performance starting off with the
classic geek meant for CPU tests so we
got a results and as you guys can see
you're getting almost two times the
multi-core score on the new 16 inch
macbook pro compared to the 2015 which
is honestly better than I expected
but for four years that's actually a
pretty decent difference and now let's
get into testing graphics with Geekbench
fours metal tests all right so we got
the graphics scores back and this is
insane the sixteen inch MacBook Pro
actually scored a hundred thousand
points in the metal test compared to
only thirty two thousand six hundred so
that's triple the performance triple the
graphics performance going from the 2015
model to the 2019 60 inch MacBook Pro
which is insane with that big of a
difference in graphics I'm actually
going to test out unit ins Heaven
benchmark the extreme preset to see the
difference for gaming performance
between these two MacBook Pros the
benchmark is finished and as you guys
can see right here we're getting almost
five times the FPS on a new 16 inch
model which is insane another big
difference and maybe the reason for that
is that this only has two gigabytes of
vram compared to eight gigabytes of vram
on the 16 inch model and we also want to
test Cinebench r20 which is a more
realistic benchmark because it heats up
both of the system's gets the fans going
and shows you more realistic performance
which you would actually see in real use
cases so the tests just finished and as
you guys can see from these scores we're
actually getting even
more than the two times performance that
we saw in Geekbench for now I think
that's because the 2015 took so much
longer that it got a lot hotter compared
to the 16 inch which finished it
relatively quickly before it got really
hot and now let's compare storage speeds
now both of these models are equipped
with one terabyte SSDs so it's an
apples-to-apples comparison so let's go
ahead and run it looking at the store
speeds on the 2015 model they're
actually not that bad but the 60 inch
macbook pro is a lot faster as you guys
can see with those scores right there
now it's very interesting is that this
2015 MacBook Pro 4 years ago it was
actually priced at $3,200 compared to
$3,500 with this specific model right
here now the differences are the RAM
first of all this one has 32 gigs of RAM
compared to 16 and this also has the
highest end processor which honestly we
would recommend not going with the 2.4
gig processor but actually going with a
2.3 gig processor would saves you $200
in that way it's actually only a $100
difference between these two and as you
guys saw from all those tests the
keyboards the speakers the microphones
the displays this is just so much better
compared to the 2015 model now if you
want to see some more in-depth
performance testing specifically in
Final Cut Pro 10 for video editing go
over to the max yuryev channel and
subscribe because he's gonna be doing a
direct comparison between these two so
hopefully you guys enjoy this comparison
comparing all this different stuff if
you guys notice some differences or
something that you liked about the 16
inch macbook pro leave a comment down
below and if you haven't already click
that circle above to subscribe and check
out those two videos right there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]